- And I realize
she's looking at a pig...
driving a car...
doing cocaine.
[dark electronic music]
♪
[wind whistling wildly]
[cheers and applause]
- Hello, everybody, welcome
to "This Is Not Happening."
I'm your host, Ari Shaffir,
and today all the stories
are about nostalgia.
[cheers and applause]
Hells, yes.
This first comic,
what an honor to introduce him.
He's absolutely hilarious,
a legend of stand-up comedy.
Please give it up
for my friend and yours--
Mr. Artie Lange,
everybody.
[cheers and applause]
- My story has to do
with cocaine, and--
[laughter and cheering]
Yeah, yeah, yeah,
listen,
I've had a love affair
with cocaine--
a love/hate affair,
you know, it's--
I mean, I'm the only guy
who ever got fat on cocaine,
as far--
I went to rehab for coke.
I swear to God--
this is a true story.
I'm in group therapy,
and this black kid
walked up to me and said,
"What are you, pouring that shit
on cheeseburgers?"
[laughter]
"God damn, you're the fattest
cokehead I ever seen?"
That's how black guys talked
in my rehab.
I went to rehab in 1888.
Uh, so, okay, I--
here's the story.
I come out here in 1995
to do a show called "MADtv."
It was a sketch-comedy show.
[cheers and applause]
Oh, oh, thank--all right.
Thank you.
I mean, you know, the show was--
it was fun, you know.
I was 27 years old,
came out here,
and the first time
I was ever out here
was the screen test
for "MADtv."
And I came out here with a job,
making, like, ten grand a week,
and it was great.
The problem was,
I brought from New York City
a massive cocaine problem.
And I somehow had
a coke problem
with $40 in my pocket
in New York.
Now I had
ten grand a week, okay?
And I literally would intercept
the checks at "MAD"--
I would go to the accounting
office at "MADtv,"
before it went to my agent.
I would get the check.
I would cash it.
I would send, like, four grand
to my mother
'cause she needed it.
I would put six grand
in my pocket
and walk around L.A. like I was
Jack fucking Nicholson,
you know.
And, you know, I had a blast,
but, you know--
I was on a train
that was gonna hit a mountain,
you know, that was--
moving real fast.
So a lot of the sketches
we did on "MADtv," we did--
we did film parodies, okay,
'cause that's "Mad"--
It was based
on "Mad" magazine,
and, you know,
you did these bad, bad puns
of movie titles,
and we'd have a pitch meeting
to pitch this stuff,
and I would just say stuff
as a joke.
Like,
instead of "Dead Man Walking,
I'd say,
"Ed McMahon Walking"...
as a joke, in the back.
Cut to me in three hours
of prosthetics
as Ed McMahon.
Stuff like--
one time, I pitched--
They told us
that Tori Spelling
had agreed to do
a guest spot on the show,
and I pitched
the Tori Spelling Bee.
And it--
[laughs]
The Tori Spelling Bee,
and she would, you know,
have to spell words,
and she would have to use words
in a sentence,
and the one word she would have
to spell was "nepotism."
[laughter]
[laughs]
And then use it in a sentence,
and the sentence was her
looking right at the camera,
going, "I like nepotism."
So stuff like that.
So one of the sketches we did
was called "Babe Watch,"
and that was Babe the Pig
in "Baywatch."
My hand to God.
So guess who played
Babe the Pig?
Moi.
And there was
a lot of fucking money
for these sketches
at the time.
We had a big budget, so we
shot it on location in Malibu.
It was a two-day shoot.
I go out there.
I had to be there at 4:00 a.m.
to get three hours
of pig prosthetics--
a pig face, a pig snout,
six teats,
the bikini top on each one--
that was the joke, you know,
and...
You didn't see us at the Emmys
a lot back then.
So, anyway, yeah.
So six teats
and a pig snout.
Now, the woman
who did the makeup
was the best in the business
at this.
So three hours of prosthetics,
I look like a fucking pig, man.
I looked in the mirror,
and I was like, "My God."
I had a pig snout covering
my mouth and my nose
and the ears and all that shit
and the teats.
So I go back
to my trailer.
We got about an hour
before we're shooting.
I go back,
and I start eating.
Now, I catch of glimpse of me
in the mirror, eating.
[laughter]
Guys, I'm--
literally, I'm going,
"I'm a fucking pig."
I'm a pig eating.
This is not why
I signed up for this, you know.
I don't want to be
in show business
to be this, you know.
So I really started
to freak out.
It was, like,
a 14-hour shoot,
and I said, "I'm not gonna get
through this without cocaine."
Not gonna happen.
So my coke dealer in New York
hooked me up with this guy,
a contact he had in L.A.
who was a coke dealer,
and this guy--
he was a Rastafarian guy.
I don't want to be,
you know, racial,
but they just happen to dominate
that business, all right?
And--
[laughter]
And he was the best
cocaine dealer ever.
He was always
right on time.
You called him, he was like,
"I'm there," you know.
He was kind of--
he was always at a party
no matter what time
of the day it was.
He was like Harvey Keitel
in "Pulp Fiction,"
you know, the--
[laughs]
The Wolf, like,
"You sending The Wolf, baby?
That's Kool and the Gang."
So I call him.
I call him from the set.
And I go,
"Dude, you got to fucking--
You got to meet me
on the Pacific Coast Highway."
We were in Malibu,
by Oxnard.
"You got to meet me.
I got to get something from you.
I got to get an eight ball
from you," and he goes,
"All right, all right, can you
get to this restaurant, Duke's--
Can you get to the restaurant
on the Pacific Coast Highway?"
And I'm like, "Yeah, yeah,
I think I can."
So I hang up with him.
I look around.
Now, I'm in every shot
of this sketch.
I look at the--
the assistant director's
not looking for two seconds.
I run to my car.
I get in my car,
and I speed the fuck away.
I just speed away.
I'm doing, like,
90 miles an hour...
looking, I'm telling you,
exactly like a pig.
I do, like, 90 up the highway,
took about 20 minutes.
I get to Duke's. I pull in.
He's already there.
The fucking guy--
[stutters]
What, were you at a brunch
at Duke's? What happened?
'Cause I mean, anyone here
who does drugs,
you got to score, you know--
you know, coke or heroin or--
you know, we all know
what it's like
to score heroin, right?
[laughter]
[laughs]
I don't know.
I was at a church social, sorry.
So, you know,
they're never there.
These guys are
never there.
You're supposed to meet them,
you know, in Brooklyn,
and you get a call
a half hour later,
the guy goes--like,
a Puerto Rican guy going,
"Yo, man,
I'm in North Carolina now."
"Excuse me?
'Cause I'm in Brooklyn."
"Yeah, man, I'm sorry.
I fucked up.
Can you get
to North Carolina?"
This guy was efficient.
Okay.
So I get there.
I get out of my car.
I run to him.
He gets out of his car.
Now, I never told him
I was on a TV show,
'cause I was afraid to, like,
share my life with him,
and I forget myself.
He sees me get
out of this car...
dressed
exactly like a pig.
And he looks at me, and--
It's so fucking--
[laughter]
I'll never forget
the look on his face.
[babbling and laughing]
When I retell this story,
this might be
the funniest fucking part.
He goes--he looks at me,
and he goes--
"Damn, man, what kind
of crazy shit are you into?"
[laughter and applause]
He probably thought
I was at some crazy drug party,
you know?
People dressed like pigs,
like the--
like the "Eyes Wide Shut"
orgy scene, you know?
What's the other password?
So I said--
I had to come clean.
"Oh, no, I'm on a TV show.
I'm doing a sketch.
Like, I'm paid--the pig--
it's a long story."
And then he goes,
"You're on a show?
What show you are on?"
and I go, "'MADtv.'"
He goes, "Oh, damn."
Look, can we talk
about this later?
I just need the coke,
you know?
He was starstruck
for a second.
So I get the cocaine
from him.
I can't pay.
I don't have anything on me.
But he was, again,
the best drug dealer ever.
He took credit. He goes,
"Fine. Don't worry about it."
So I grab the coke,
and now I'm, like, so freaked,
I got to do some.
I have to do some immediately,
just to get myself ready
for what I'm going back to.
I get back in my car, and anyone
who's ever had a cocaine problem
knows what a key hit is.
You put--
If you don't have a straw,
you know,
you put some coke
on a key.
You know this, right?
[laughs]
[laughter]
I apologize. You look
really grossed out by me, but--
[laughter]
For a ton of reasons,
but--
So I put some coke--
Again, forgetting
what I look like--
I put some coke
on the end of a key.
I go to do it.
I can't get the coke
through the pig snout.
I can't do it,
so now I'm thinking--
[laughs] I'm the only one
in the history of the world
who's ever had
this problem.
So now, three hours
of prosthetics
I went through, okay?
And I'm trying to get
the fucking, you know, key
through the thing.
I can't do it,
so I'm like, "Fuck it."
I make a decision.
I break the fucking nose,
which means
when I get back there,
it's gonna be an hour
of fixing it before we shoot.
I'm in every shot.
So I break the fucking pig nose.
I do a couple of blasts.
I'm like,
"Okay, I'm fine."
Now I get back
on the Pacific Coast Highway,
I rush back towards Oxnard.
I stop at a light
at Topanga Canyon,
and I figure I'm gonna do
another hit.
It's broad daylight.
It's, like, 8:00 in the morning.
[laughs]
[laughter]
So I do another hit.
I got the--
I got it up to my nose
like this,
I look over, and
there's this beautiful woman
in a Lamborghini.
This is the look
on her face...
[laughter]
And I realize
she's looking at a pig...
driving a car...
doing cocaine.
Then I'm thinking,
you know, "Fuck her.
"This is L.A.
It's probably the third time
she saw that that day."
[laughs]
At this point, I have no--
I'm like, "Fuck it.
I don't care who sees what."
So I do another hit. I drive.
I get to the fucking set.
Everybody wants to kill me,
but they can't really
say it yet,
because we got to do
14 hours of shooting.
So they see that my fucking nose
is fucked up.
They have to redo my nose,
and, you know,
we start shooting,
and everybody couldn't stand--
Look, I was a fuck-up.
Every two hours, I broke
the nose again to do coke,
and every two hours,
she had to fix it.
And she knew what was going on.
I wasn't fooling anybody.
So this happens.
We get through the day,
and it's a nightmare.
So we had to shoot
the next day.
They got us a little motel
right on the ocean there,
which was next to the shoot,
So I go in.
I fall asleep.
They rip all the shit
off me.
I fall asleep in the bed.
I wake up the next morning.
At some point
during the night,
every bad thing in my body
must have just fell out of me.
I mean, yeah, I just--
I shit the bed.
And I had a lot of bad
in me.
I wake up--you know the scene
in "The Godfather,"
the horse's head, where he
wakes up, he sees all the blood?
I was like...
[screaming]
[laughs]
I had shit all over the bed.
I was late.
I had no time to clean it up.
I I took
a steaming-hot shower,
steaming hot, every--
took everything off,
got dressed, ran out.
I had no time. We were checking
out of the hotel.
I had no time to clean up.
So I just threw the bedspread
over all the shit.
I mean, it was
a river of shit.
I just threw it
over the fucking thing and left.
What could I do,
you know?
I had no cash for a tip...
which is very rude.
And I got there.
I got through the day.
Everything was fine.
So we're driving home,
and I'm thinking about the
hotel, and I'm worried about it.
I'm like, "Ah, well, you know,
I'm just gonna have to be
embarrassed by that,"
but then I realized
the room wasn't in my name.
The room was in the name of
the first assistant director...
[laughter]
This guy Josh, you know.
If they want to blame somebody,
they're gonna say,
"This guy Josh, you know,
shit the bed
and didn't clean up,"
which got me off the hook,
but it made me feel happy/
It really did.
The Rasta guy,
the coke dealer--
again, he was the single--
the single coolest motherfucker,
as far as fast living,
didn't care.
About two years later,
I found out that he--
he was
in a metallic-blue Corvette
driving with this chick
he dated
up a winding street
up by Northern California.
He was doing, like,
100 miles an hour, veered off,
hit a 18-wheeler, and just--
the two people disintegrated.
That's how he died,
so he's dead.
And I'll tell you what,
in the weirdest of ways--
and this is
why I'm a fuck-up in life
and I care
about all the wrong things.
In the weirdest of ways,
I miss that motherfucker
more than anybody
I've ever met
in Los Angeles.
My name's Artie Lange.
That's my story.